ING MEMBERS OF THE  TEAM.EWA UMO
H NTRYT A HOUSE OFFICE BS SAYS
MEMBOFGRAYNANTENT.OR REPORTE
OLIVER DARCY JOINS MOE
FOCA
WH MUTTHIS, AND WHATEL
E WHY
>>I A TYPICA C
OR ANYONE W
THLMING WED
A COMEDYD TH HEARINGS.
DAY THEY DID SOM
T TH WLY, THONTED BYLICE OUTSIDA
HAENEY WERPA
HAT POIN PIL E ASKED
P OF
PRODUCONAM THEM WIWFUL ENTRY ON.
PIAYIS AN ONGOING VEHEY'REOOMO
CHARGES, BUT YEAH, TS ISOTNORMA.
E VIEW
LT'S, WE HEOERE, THE COMIC
JIM.
>>T IND AN
ACCOMPLI JAL
TRIUMPH'S IVE M. NCAPI
OUR LEADER GATHERED FOR  PROCES
ABOUT THTHESHEAR, O SIT SO MURS
EL SOUTHAROLIN LAUGH.NTION WITHE
I'M SORRY,S MAKEE
I.
>> YEAH,UM
ABLE TO GET OUD,W,  SCARR BLIVEI
SOUNDS AS OUGHHIS INCIDENT
6th RRECTION Y TEAH, JIM, SO WA
STIGHT WING MEDIISLS
FOX BROKE THIS STORYT NIGHT,THE
RR THAT OCCURRED ON
TONGT Y 6th.THEY'RE BASILLT S P
E.LINARY ACTION THAT THE
YOU RORIES PLAYING OUE MOTHINK,
NG WH
AND WHAT'S